Jamie smiling still to this day always
having a smile on your face such a
positive light on this show I mean it's
bittersweet to be talking to you today
um you're so close to making it to the
final five how are you feeling now that
everything is out there your friends
your family have seen it all play out
yes thank you so much for having me I
feel amazing it's such a huge
accomplishment getting to final six and
being able to celebrate with my friends
and family it was amazing to watch it
back all season and you know laugh about
it and celebrate together and it it's
been an amazing journey I'm so
incredibly grateful for it's hard not to
smile when your dream is literally
actually coming true you know even just
being there is something that I I'm
never gonna get over that it's like it's
it's
a dream come true
oh that's amazing to hear I'm so glad to
hear that now I have to get this out of
the way quickly when you first made it
to Ponderosa and you found out that your
fake Idol that came or his the idol that
you came took was fake what was your
reaction to that news
eventually when I find out about it I am
shocked I immediately you just start
rewinding every single play and
conversation that you have because
you're really thinking about your game
as if you have a real Idol and designing
plays with a real Idol and you know
um a part of me kind of wishes like I
wish I would have been able to play the
fake Idol to have that iconic moment of
Jeff throwing it in the fire like oh I
wish I could have been a part of that
and laughed about it and I I I am
oh I I
I'm still in shock by it all and and
finding it out it's you just rewind and
even rewind because then it rewinds to
the moment I found it I was like wait a
second and there was a split second not
anything to even get a credit for a
split second where I said is this real
is this real and then I like did a post
check with everyone I'm like no I've
really I've I've kept track of where
everyone is no one has had the time to
make this beautifully crafted Idol that
looks real I mean it looks exactly like
the beaded Idol and the paper was so
crisp and white and clean I'm like
there's no way that this has been in
somebody's pocket like this is real you
know you have a split second but you're
like I'm what I've got an idol this is
and you just because it is part of like
a Survivor bucket list moment to find an
idol and to have it drop in my lap like
that it was just a dream another dream
come true all the dreams coming true
even if it was a fake idle at the end
it's still something you found it's
still something you played your game
with so we'll take that as a win now I
have to ask you after the immunity
challenge did you have any sense or
feeling of vulnerability or were you
confident with how you thought the cards
were gonna lie at tribal
you know I had developed a relationship
with Lauren and I were working very
close
with the uh together the entire game but
we had also developed I had a really
close relationship with Jam Jam
um much of it obviously it's not seen my
relationship with Jam jam and Carson and
then uh
Lauren having relations with Carson
because he came over to Route 2 when I
left Ahsoka there was a foursome
conversation happening and we had a lot
of trust in Carson and in Jam jam
and and really you know with watching
how they would vote and seeing
especially the last two votes like okay
perfect like we're they they are working
with us and they did betray you know one
of their alliance members so it was
um
yeah I think going into it I thought
that it would be solid because they made
it a goal to convince Lauren and I that
Carolyn was a bigger threat and to me it
was like wait a second but Carson's a
bigger threat like he's like the brain's
here he has like a great resume and he's
positioning himself socially so well and
mitigating his Threat Level and and
really would be able to outspeak anyone
to his game at this point and so we need
to Target him but they made it a they
they made it heavily focused on
um why Carolyn was a threat and for
Lauren and I it was hard to see that
because we had just met her at the merge
and she had done a great job at putting
Jam jam and Carson out to build
relationships with everybody else
because you know I didn't really have a
close relationship with Carolyn and so
it was like okay yeah let's go ahead and
if you I'll go with the flow if you guys
want to say she's the biggest target
then let's do it and I certainly hope
that I had been managing my Threat Level
to to really not be threatening at all
considering
the target was the idol
um and having to kind of brush that off
so
going into it
um I thought that the votes would be
solid but then right before tribal
Carson came up to me to double check
like hey by the way this is what the
votes are going to be right it's still
Carolyn right which he which was a
Telltale sign it was like that intuition
thing where you're like wait uh wait why
is he double checking like he never does
this and then that's when I started
thinking like it's me oh my gosh it's
gonna be me and then it and then we had
to get on the boat to go to tribal yeah
and you kind of get this Eerie feeling
when it's you like that intuition yeah
and I was like wait it's not like this
feels kind of weird like what's
happening and then as we see everything
um unfold as soon as I saw my name I was
like
you're like love you guys but I know
it's me yes like the moment that I saw
my name I was like okay it's the Tikka
three are you surprised that they stayed
the ticket three stayed strong and even
Heidi went with them because at at some
point like as a viewer I was convinced
that jam Jam was going to turn on
Carolyn and I didn't know what was gonna
happen but were you surprised that they
stayed Tika strong yes I I I was
surprised because
especially going back to the Franny vote
we you know part of our
um solidifying relationships the only
way that you can solidify something is
like by proving it in a vote and so
with
Carson and jam Jam you know I wanted to
make it clear like hey by the way we
have to keep Carolyn out of this she
cannot know because she's too close to
Franny so please like you know and then
um Lauren and I had Franny as a target
from that from when Cain walked out the
door it was like okay we've got to get
Freddy out of here this is like she's
gonna Bulldog she's an amazing game
player we can't we can't have our sit at
the end and so
um to to us it was oh my gosh yes they
voted with us and then we were able to
distract height or to distract Carolyn
and Franny in that vote by saying hey
let's write down Heidi and have and not
Luke Heidi in so that she still writes
down Danny so Lauren and I are kind of
causing riffs in all of these alliances
and knowing where each of the votes go
specifically during the Franny vote and
after that vote it was like yes Jam jam
and Carson are earning my trust by
proving it at Tribal Council and voting
as such and Carolyn was in the
background so much so that we didn't
really have a relationship with her at
all so we're you know thinking okay
like that I get that they're very close
and it makes sense why they would want
to Target her than first because we
weren't aware of really how close they
were
um but that was kind of like the proof
and and props to them for leveraging
that in a way to where it would build
trust with Lauren and I so that they
could use us as resources in their game
wow that is I never thought about that
and it's so interesting hearing your
perspective from everything because we
only get to see so much on the show
right
um and lastly I just want to ask you you
know you said it was a dream to be on
Survivor you accomplished so many
amazing things you met so many amazing
people but what would you say was your
biggest takeaway or lesson that you
learned
um in Fiji when you were on the show oh
laughs
the biggest lesson I learned in Fiji was
really I'm like I'm trying not to be
cliche I promise it is always believe in
yourself bet on yourself you can do
anything you can do anything
like after playing this game it's like I
can do anything Lego what's next you
know we slept on the island for I was
out there for 23 days and like sleeping
on a beach in the cold by the fire yeah
it's like if you can get through that
you can do anything and so now it's uh
um a constant reminder of that like
watching this back it's like
yeah so I think that's that is the
Brilliance and the lesson that came out
of this is like always believe in
yourself and anything's possible you can
do anything
oh I absolutely love that well it was an
absolute absolute pleasure to watch you
on the show we're still gonna see you on
the jury when you're not gone yet but um
thank you so much for talking with me
today and I'm excited for the rest of
the season and still excited to see you
on a little TV screen so thank you so
much thank you